in the previous video we motivated
somebody definite programming by a toy
geometry problem today we will see a
much more useful and much more realistic
application of semi-definite programming
to a different problem related this time
to dynamical systems
an important question in dynamical
system theory is to test whether a given
dynamical system is asymptotically
stable or intuitively whether it always
converges to the equilibrium
this is an extremely important concept
in engineering for example let's say we
model a plane as a dynamical system if
there is turbulence we would really like
to know whether the plane would go back
to its equilibrium state or whether it
will do something crazy
in mathematics we like to model the
state of a system at time t by a vector
u t that represents for example the
position and orientation of the plane at
time t plus one the system will reach
another state ut plus one that is
related to the current state by some
function f
the most common and best studied
functions f are definitely the linear
ones where f of u is equal to some
matrix a times u in this linear setting
asymptotic stability means that if you
start from some initial state to zero
and you keep multiplying by the same
matrix a again and again the trajectory
converges to the origin eventually and
that for any initial state you zero
if you pose for a moment and try to
think about how you would decide
something like this how would you decide
whether a given linear dynamical system
is stable or not two difficulties that
have to do with infinity will arise
first to show convergence of this
sequence we need to consider infinitely
many time steps t and second we need to
consider all possible starting states to
zero it makes you wonder if there is
even an algorithm that takes the matrix
a as input and returns infinite time
whether the associated dynamical system
is stable or not
we will show today that yes such an
algorithm exists and amazingly is based
on a clever application of semi-definite
programming the idea of this algorithm
originated from the russian
mathematician alexander leoponov his
observation is as follows imagine there
is a function v that is positive
everywhere except at the origin where
it's zero such that its value decreases
after each step of our dynamical system
if such a function exists then all
trajectories must converge to the origin
intuitively this is because if some
trajectory did not converge to zero
v of u of t will decrease indefinitely
and eventually it will become negative
which cannot happen because v is not
negative by definition
such a function v is called a lyapunov
function and you can think of it as some
energy associated with the system that
decreases along trajectories
the great thing about this idea of
leoponov is that it is an if and only if
statement a linear dynamical system is
asymptotically stable if and only if
there exists a layup on a function
this is great and all but how is this
helpful it's true that we have reduced
the problem of test and stability to
testing whether a layup on a function
exists or not but practically how do we
find such a layup on a function in the
first place if anything maybe finding
such a function is a much harder task
than solving the problem we started with
and this is where the time we spent on
semi-definite programming will pay off
so bear with me for a second
to search for layup on a function v we
need two insights
first we will assume that v is as simple
as possible but not any simpler than
that for example we cannot take v itself
to be a linear function because linear
functions take negative values we can't
try quadratic functions though or in
other words functions of the form u
transpose p u for some matrix p the
second insight is that the task of
searching for a quadratic function v
that satisfies lyapunov requirements is
a semi-definite programming in disguise
to see that note that the constraint v
of 0 equals 0 is automatically satisfied
the positivity constraint is exactly the
same as the matrix pv and positive
definite and the constraint v of ut plus
1 smaller than v of u of t is the same
as a times u times p times a times u is
smaller than u p times u
or in other terms after a slight
rearrangement it's the same as the
matrix p minus a transpose pa being
positive definite
and that's it as written this is almost
a semi-definite program we are looking
for a matrix speed that satisfies a
bunch of matrix inequalities
i say almost because so far there is no
objective function and the inequalities
are strict
but semi-definite programming only
supports non-strict inequalities
as far as picking an objective function
is concerned you can pick any function
you want for example even the constant
function 0 would work here
how about the strict inequalities
well it turns out that this is not a big
issue either without laws of generality
and by scaling this matrix p with a
large positive scalar if necessary we
can replace the strict inequalities with
larger or equal than the identity matrix
which is another way of saying that
after subtracting the identity we want
the resulting matrix to be positive
semi-definite
let's now jump to python and see how we
can do this
so we have our matrix a that gives the
linear dynamical system ut plus one
equals a times ut and just for fun we
can use this code to generate a sample
trajectory from this dynamical system
you can see that this particular
trajectory converges to zero but in
order to show that all trajectories
converge to zero we need to find a layup
on a function so let's look for a layup
on a function of the four mu transpose
pu with semi-definite programming as
usual we import the package cbx pi we
declare a matrix p to which we impose
the layout of constraints we talked
about and we call the solve method and
just like that we obtain the following
layup on a function which shows that our
dynamical system is indeed
asymptotically stable if you run the
exact same code with a different matrix
a like this one for example the solver
will tell you that the semi-difference
program is infeasible which shows that
the corresponding dynamical system is
not stable and this is something you
might have guessed by looking at this
sample trajectory for example
that's all for today thank you very much
for watching if you liked the video
please like and subscribe and see you
next time